all right welcome to a new video just
out of curiosity I just press the 960
button so I got a 960 Blitz game 3-1
here okay hope you don't mind for a
change because I didn't get a 5-minute
opponent quickly so okay let's get the
starting position sorted out I have a
bishop on a nice diagonal of course
white also potentially this is why I
played g6 2 to get the bishop active and
it's all looking very strange as usual
in 916 zombie f5 f5 and ship to have 7
potentially maybe should have seven now
what about D 65 50 65 here trying to
grab some central space ok he went for
four long castles this was the the whole
idea of his setup I guess
maybe still your wife
want to open it up here and establish
some points of the center it's it's
still normal chess after all okay okay
maybe drop back here and Knight to f6
have some pressure on d5 okay he wants
to play your form okay but if I play F
for now but some quite a question what
the bishop on h1 will be doing in this
game okay so I want to protect the night
on e 7 so that I can play okay he wants
to free this a bit but okay I can take
here and then 9 to h5 potentially
occupying a forint trying to exchange
this somewhat lousy Bishop on g7 okay my
dears Bishop g7 9 to g8 Bishop to h6
okay I haven't cancelled yet I actually
could do I could do short castling here
right getting the the King from ba to g8
I could also do long castles but it
doesn't make much sense now
all right I'm actually surprised that
I've got a rating here maybe I I press
this button accidentally reform okay I
want to go night to g8 Bishop to h6 and
play on this week scram all right maybe
he wants to go h4 bishop h3 but similar
idea but I was threatening this also
with the King on on c1 so all right and
now I think Bishop f4 would be would be
nice for me to exchange the bishop this
is also why I didn't cancel long yet
that a7 is not hanging okay hmm
it doesn't make much sense to take on h3
here time warning yeah my development is
not so great
should I play maybe this one that I can
capture with the rook here just need to
speed up a bit want to take with the
Queen on e5
okay time for for castling I need to
look badly here and f8
very low on time okay I'm glad that I
could that I got rid of the Queen City
the sounds a bit also allows for
somewhat weaker moves
okay now the looks kind of oops
you just blended this rook white resigns
oops
this was a quite quite sudden and here
um yeah why should have Jake and I guess
just just take here so I went through
premade but this is some already a
somewhat problematic endgame because
he's got all this fancy on on light
squares what was certainly better before
surprisingly I think maybe maybe is this
this Bishop f4 was a bit premature I
need to maybe get my pieces some more
active first like Knight a to f6 or
something I'm not sure it's a it's quite
it's quite weird because somehow
somehow I'm not I'm not in position to
to hold there's a Foursquare okay I
could have gone g5 yeah if you what
doesn't this work
I can't just just quickly here I took on
a phone I know this Bishop e8 yeah maybe
I need to play g5 here why can't I move
it's a weird g5 maybe g5 hmm in order to
to place this kind of position which
should be nice with the space advantage
but I wanted to have a piece on f4 but
didn't really manage so maybe it would
have been better not to play this
immediately but maybe play move like
this year first and somehow improve the
positions and the positions of the
pieces this and short castles or
something alright okay it was quite
quite quite fun to to do a 960 game okay
thanks for watching